12 est à présent face à la première
[Musique]
nous sommes à 91 jours du premier tour
de scrutin des élections territoriales
dans toute la france les quelques 5000
membres des assemblées délibérantes des
collectivités locales seront renouvelés
ou pas cela dépendra du souhait des
électeurs chez nous ce sont les
instances de la ctm l'assemblée le
conseil exécutif qui sont concernés par
ces élections dont les deux tours de
scrutin auront lieu les 13 et 20 juin à
7e prépare le budget de 2021 qui se veut
offensif afin de surmonter la crise
sanitaire et refonder la martinique
selon les termes du président du conseil
exécutif alfred marie jeanne
un sujet que nous verrons dans quelques
instants nous parlerons aussi du vote de
l'assemblée en faveur de la
relocalisation aux mains du gouvernement
de la gestion du rsa le revenu de
solidarité active qui pèse trop lourd
dans les caisses de la collectivité avec
moi dans nos studios de la tour
luminaires trois élus de la collectivité
territoriale de martinique dans le cadre
de notre série d'émissions sur le bilan
et l'avenir de la ctm dont c'est le
dixième volet aujourd'hui je vous
souhaite la bienvenue dans face à la
première en ce dimanche 14 mars à
l'ecoute de l'émission politique
hebdomadaire de la rédaction de
martinique la première nous inviter à
cette émission réalisée par un cedrick
banks les héros du xl calixte heures
tout d'abord manu la prime bertolo
bonjour madame crème bertolo bonjour
monsieur petit bonjour et auditrices
vous remercie d'avoir accepté notre
invitation en particulier à cette
émission c'est une première pour vous
tout à fait sûrement pas une dernière
bouffée un bien conseiller à l'assemblée
de martinique élus de la majorité à ce
titre vous êtes présidente du cca le
campus caraïbéen d alex ira au fond ce
qui ne voit pas très bien où ça c'est
qu'elle est qu'elles s'étaient cette
école vous êtes une militante du mime le
mouvement indépendantiste martiniquais
et 2
dans le civil si je bute champion vous
en vous avez vous êtes dirigeant d'un
organisme du secteur de l'économie
sociale vous êtes âgé de 55 ans
implantée à william pilote fait avec
nous en studio nadine renard bonjour
madame rohner bonjour monsieur parenti
et bonjour à mes chers collègues bonjour
aux auditeurs de martinique première
conseillère à l'assemblée de martinique
élus de la majorité où vous présidez la
commission du développement agricole de
l'agro transformation et de l'élevage
les mots ont un sens vous êtes ingénieur
en grand en agroalimentaire de
profession ceci expliquant peut-être
cela
âgé de 47 ans a implanté à cette marie
vous avez même été deuxième adjointe du
maire bruno nestor azérot pendant
quelques mois en 2008 2009
mais quel est votre sensibilité
politique parce que on a parfois du mal
à vous situer sur dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée
alors je suis sans étiquette 1 je suis
je n'adhère à aucun parti
je suis bien sûr élus de la majorité
j'ai été élu sur la liste du grand
ensemble et est donc pour moi il s'agit
à travers les cinq ans on a passé dans
cette collectivité territoriale de
martinique je sens que j'ai pu à travers
les différentes missions à différents
projets que j'ai mené travailler avec
l'ensemble des élus quelle que soit leur
couleur politique majorité comme
opposition et donc
donc voilà donc aujourd'hui je suis sans
étiquette même si effectivement j'ai des
affinités avec telle ou telle tendance
de l'assemblée très bien merci de ces
précisions et enfin marie-france tino
bonjour madame pinault bonjour monsieur
partie
bonjour chers collègues bonjour les
martiniquais et bonjour également à ceux
qui nous écoutent et alexis lyonnais
martinique vient le net
en effet ea qui sont très nombreuses et
nombreux en effet puisque je rappelle
que cette émission est un radio filmée
donc elle est diffusée aussi bien en
radio le dimanche à 12h et 17h que sur
notre site internet dès le lendemain
vous êtes te conseiller à l'assemblée de
martinique également élu de l'opposition
au sein de la coalition au pmn ensemble
pour une martinique nouvelle pour
militer au mouvement populaire francis
qu'elle mpf vous est implanté au
françois
vous avez d'ailleurs été adjointe au
maire maurice antiste de 2001 à 2020 et
vous êtes dans l'opposition depuis les
dernières élections municipales de 2020
vous êtes la responsable administrative
d'un centre de formation professionnelle
âgé de 61 ans mesdames merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation avant de
rentrer dans le vif du sujet dont on a
parlé de la gestion de la crise
sanitaire qui pose problème au budget de
la 7e et puis de ce budget qui sera voté
dans quelques jours le 25 févr
25 mars prochain quelques questions
d'actualité tout d'abord aujourd'hui
c'est le 14 ans coïncidence du
calendrier le 14 mars 1971 il y avait
des élections municipales 14 mars 2021
cela fait exactement 50 ans qu'elles ont
eu lieu est l'un des maires élus à ce
moment là il faisait partie de ce qu'on
appelait les maires rouger maire dit de
gauche autonomiste et indépendantiste ou
favorable à l'autogestion alfred
marie-jeanne est le dernier de ses sept
mers dernier survivant puisque les
autres sont décédés donc manier la crème
bertolo comme vous êtes avec nous c'est
une date c'est un événement qui me
semble important de souligner mais c'est
bien que vous le soulignez effectivement
ça me ramène à je vais dire à hama plus
temps de l'enfance puisque je me
rappelle effectivement de 7 2 se joue
fait où il ya eu ces élections et où mes
parents étaient en plein dans le marché
on a eu à fêter la victoire de de semer
rouge comme vous dites et qu'il a
effectivement manqué
à marquer cette commune par ces actions
je vais dire très militante et de
responsabilité qui a forgé en fait une
identité à un bloc avec manfred mann
jeunes ont été élus
le même jour un estivant n'a joui
socialiste au françois maurice joseph
theubet socialiste à ducos casimir grand
guidon socialiste à trinité et edward
jean-elie favorables à l'indépendance a
ajouté mme bouillon ces quatre
personnalités étant décédés depuis voilà
donc actualité encore 448 millions
d'euros pour nos hôpitaux la bonne
nouvelle a été annoncée par le directeur
général de la rs il y a quelques jours
dans la foulée de la déclaration du
premier ministre que du ministre de la
santé
9 milliards d'euros à l'échelle de toute
la france pour les 10 ans dont 440
millions pour la martinique et notamment
70 millions pour reconstruire l'hôpital
de trinité mesdames c'est une bonne
nouvelle marie faustino je vois que oui
tout à fait c'est une bonne nouvelle
mais bon il faut savoir aussi que c'est
pas cette nouvelle n'est pas arrivé
comme ça il ya eu un long travail et je
tiens d'ailleurs à saluer tout le
personnel des hôpitaux à tout ce que
fait un travail depuis des années que
nous pouvons faire en sorte que parce
que ça a été un long combat et de
désillusion en désillusion quand même
hein alors aujourd'hui on est tous
contents mais bon je passerai encore
fait et puis un aussi à lui aussi quand
même cette somme est arrivé parce que la
martinique avait déjà un projet bon pour
un beau projet on va parler du projet de
2 le giron topol et c'est parce que
quand on voit quand on nous a ordonné
aux hôpitaux nous voyons les talents de
nos hôpitaux nouvelle nous entendons le
personnel il était temps est vraiment et
elle se combat là méritent d'être
saluées par nous tous parce que c'est
une mission régalienne vous rendez
compte que les nouveaux partis
travailler et vous devez vous battre
pour vos soeurs vous ferez à vos pairs
voir des côtes alors et je me dis que si
il ne faisait pas ce combat parce que ça
lui aujourd'hui on a le corps vivant n'a
d'autres choix le cancer il ya des
maladies donc c'est parce qu'on balle
qui se faisait aujourd'hui la mort du
curseur et la martinique aujourd'hui
donc moi je sais que la santé c'est une
préoccupation je dis pas que l'état ne
fait pas son travail mais elle je pense
que il ya eu trop de laisser aller au
niveau des hôpitaux donc aujourd'hui
nous le savions je vais à l'hôpital la
trinité aussi à une cour où travaille le
fait parler les syndicats et tout ça et
moi je je sais c'est un bon je tire mon
chapeau à toutes ces personnes et je dis
donc un beau chapeau à toutes les
personnes qui travaillent dans les
hôpitaux je vais parler des 2175
professionnels de santé qui est en
souffrance les 686 médecins et bien
entendu les 992 étudiants et internes
parce que ça fait tout un peuple tout un
tas de personnes qui étaient dans la
souffrance et merci pour ces personnes
merci pour la martinique le madame
honneur vous que vous êtes tout
particulièrement satisfaite d'autant que
l'hôpital de dignité va être en fait
reconstruire après des années d année
j'allais dire de jouer au chat et à la
souris entre les différentes
administrations de l'état
la population du nord atlantique duquel
où vous résidez où vous travaillez vous
vivez a de quoi être soulagé tout va
bientôt de je crois qu'effectivement
cette cette nouvelle était quand même
très attendu et je rejoins tout à fait
ce que disait marie faustino sur le fait
qu'il ya eu il faut saluer la
mobilisation des personnels de santé
depuis de nombreuses années pour pouvoir
sans relâche un ils se sont mobilisés
avec parfois le sentiment de ne pas être
entendu de ne pas être soutenus
donc il ya à la fois la mobilisation des
personnels 200 de santé pour pouvoir
arriver à ce résultat aujourd'hui
maintenant tout n'est pas gagné
il ya aussi des échéances à tenir donc
je crois que l'hôpital de trinité le
projet étant déjà bien avancé sera déjà
la premier en priorité et c'est un
hôpital qui était absolument
indispensable de maintenir sur le
territoire nord parce que on a une
population dont le nom qui une
population vieillissante et donc qui ça
suppose forcément des besoins en termes
de d'accompagnement au niveau de la de
la santé et du médico social important
puisqu'à la fois ces financements sont
prévus tant pour les hôpitaux que pour
les établissements médico sociaux
donc je pense que ça ouvre des
perspectives et ça redonne une bouffée
d'oxygène aussi à tous ces personnels
soignants qui était un petit peu usé un
de ses combats sans sans solution sans
réponse donc aujourd'hui à de nouvelles
perspectives qui s'ouvrent la
collectivité territoriale a eu également
bien souvent à suppléer à l'état sur un
certain nombre de choses dans le champ
de la santé
donc maintenant il s'agira de mettre en
oeuvre de définir les priorités et puis
de mettre en oeuvre très rapidement
puisqu'il ya quand même des contraintes
de délais dans l'utilisation de ces
financements
donc il faut que très rapidement les
projets soient finalisées qu'ils soient
priorisées qu'il soit mis en oeuvre pour
que ces crédits puissent être utilisés
efficacement pour notre territoire
je crois qu'on peut aussi se satisfaire
du fait que la gestion de ces fonds
seraient également une gestion
décentralisée donc avec la possibilité
localement de décidé de prioriser donc
est loin qu'au pilotage avec avec les
communes et les élus de manière plus
large
donc je crois que ça permettra aussi à
travers l'utilisation des fonds
européens que la collectivité a eu
l'occasion de mobiliser massivement ces
dernières années sur l'hôpital sur les
équipements et les infrastructures de
pouvoir être complémentaire je dirais en
mobilisant ses fonds européens en
complément des fonds de l'état pour
développer une offre de santé qui soit à
la hauteur des attentes de notre
population qui a vraiment besoin
d'outils structurants et le gérontopôle
par exemple est un projet très
intéressant également un compagnie manie
la plume bertolo ces thèmes seront
intégrés c'est à dire concernés par la
gestion de cette enveloppe financière
pour la reconstruction et la
réhabilitation de la rénovation
quel serait d'après vous la priorité à
part évidemment
hors construction trinité qui est
quasiment chantier quel autre priorité
faudrait-il dégagé en tout cas ce que ce
qui serait important de soutenir
du point de vue de la viième alors avant
toute chose comme comme l'ont fait mes
collègues que j'avais mais je vais me
rallier à ce à cette mobilisation au
fait au niveau des professionnels et
salué la mobilisation mais j'ai envie de
dire effectivement que 448 millions dont
70 pour l'hôpital de trinité c'est une
avancée mais j'estime que ça n'est pas
suffisant parce qu'effectivement il y à
d'autres priorités il y à celle
notamment de du chu de l'hôpital
d'aubenas kipman qui est quand même un
hôpital qui est relativement si
l'hôpital qui très certainement devra
être comment dirais-je parce qu'il ya de
l'amiante il faudra très certainement
extraits il y à ça mais il ya aussi des
questions des problématiques de
renforcement des équipes
alors quid aussi des différents services
qui vont être mises en place
bien sûr il est question de réorganiser
de moderniser mais comment avec quelle
comment dirais-je avec l échéance avec
kelly jean sié il y a également par
exemple on a entendu les professionnels
et syndicats se mobiliser sur la
question du service d'addictologie et
donc est ce que c'est un service qu'il
allait ouvrir donc il ya aussi des
questions qu'il faudra poser en termes
d'équipement en termes de modernisation
au terme de ressources humaines donc il
y a tout volé en deux et je pense que
les 448 millions ne suffiront pas compte
tenu du fait que il ne faudra pas
regarder je vais dire si vous dites
avoir des positions très ciblé parce que
il faudra regarder de manière globale et
et en fait on est obligé de constater le
désengagement de l'état dans une de ses
fonctions régaliennes qui est la santé
quand on regarde effectivement il y à
l'hôpital de trinité qui est
effectivement une priorité mais il ya
aussi l'hôpital du saint-esprit il y a
voilà il ya le marin où il ne faut pas
non plus que que qu'on fasse des
découpes mettre des petits pansements il
faut effectivement avoir une vision
globale de la santé ne permet même pas
de l'hôpital de lorient
alors quand même il faut quand même
qu'il faut quand même prendre en compte
de soutien de la collectivité au niveau
de la santé et donc madame neuronale a
dit en suppléance de l'état puisqu'on
peut on peut déjà constater que
l'hôpital de saint joseph a été soutenue
par la collectivité territoriale de
martinique
autre sujet d'actualité avant d'arriver
au budget de la 7e c'est une nouvelle
crise au sein de l'université des
antilles avec une pendant un débat en
forme de question faut-il conserver
l'université tel quel j'ai envie de
m'excuser avec deux pôles autonomes en
tout cas sur le papier guadeloupe et
martinique ou au contraire faut-il créer
deux universités une innovante unique
sachant que ce n'est pas le débat du
jour celle d'ubs avait lieu il ya deux
ans et qui aurait fermé parce qu'on a
constaté n'ont ni qu'on les élus
politiques doublés martin mais surtout
la communauté universitaire que ce
n'était pas le bon chemin
est-ce qu'on ne risque pas de revenir à
ces débats ou au contraire il faudrait
peut-être renforcer les structures de
gouvernance et d'un fonctionnement de
l'université marie faustino oui alors
aujourd'hui on constate que ce débat là
q vous aviez vieux puisque depuis le
temps de madame couinements 6 k ster et
fait des propositions parce que je sais
qu'elle n'était pas pour justement la
cession du pôle
parce que quand on constate aujourd'hui
que en france par exemple les
universités se mettre ensemble et puis
bon nous en martinique et en guadeloupe
doivent arriver là nous sommes deux îles
très proche est bon je me dis dommage
pour notre jeunesse de maïs ou la
martinique mais mais il ya des problèmes
les problèmes c'est sur les problèmes
budgétaires enfin disons de comment
dirais-je d'orientation budgétaire de
répartition des budgets etc
donc si à ce problème là si une scène
peut pas se régler donc je ne pense qu'à
un moment donné mais je pense que les
politiques et l'état devant prendre ce
problème à bras le corps pour arriver à
une situation parce que bon on a connu
quand même des moments l'université de
guadeloupe accueillait vice versa les
universités des étudiants ont pas
rentable au cref emporté pour autre
chose les ligues bien venez en
martinique
donc aujourd'hui je pense qu' il fallait
peut-être qu'on arrive à un consensus ou
que parce que ça fait un moment que ça
dure et notre jeunesse qui a besoin
justement d'études j'ai rencontré de
difficulté ça n'avance pas donc moi je
dirais que est ce qu'il faudrait moi je
me pose une question je m'étais moi je
n'ai pas la solution mais aujourd'hui
est ce qu'il faudrait justement qui a
une scission des deux ports en question
question justement que je pose la main
de renard 2 universités ou bien une
seule reforcer ou en tout cas à pezi de
ce prometteur
je crois qu'on est tous d'accord sur le
fait qu'il faudrait déjà que le débat
soit apaisée mais la question se pose
pleinement et je crois qu'ils la
problématique de l'université est
complexe puisque on a à la fois une
situation particulièrement dégradé au
niveau des relations et de la
gouvernance qui fait qu'aujourd'hui les
conditions de fonctionnement et de vie
universitaire pour les étudiants sur
cette université des antilles ils sont
difficiles maintenant il ya un problème
enfin des problèmes de fond qui sont des
problèmes structurels conjoncturel aussi
puisqu'on a une université un pôle
martinique qui aujourd'hui
compte tenu de la baisse démographique
et ses pairs des étudiants par un pont
peut-être à la guadeloupe où on est sur
une nombre d'étudiants plus important et
donc ça a forcément un effet mécanique
quand on compte tenu des règles de
répartition des moyens des budgets et
c'est donc forcément ça a des
répercussions donc aujourd'hui je crois
qu'il faut vraiment repenser cette
université des antilles il ya un certain
nombre il ya une mission d'évaluation
parlementaire qui a été mené par la
députée josette manin qui fait un
certain nombre de préconisations au
gouvernement sur sur des pistes de
réponses à apporter à certaines
problématiques qui minent un petit peu
aujourd'hui le fonctionnement de de
cette université des antilles donc à mon
sens je crois qu'il faut il faut à la
fois mettre en oeuvre ces actions donc
l'état a toute sa part à prendre
puisqu'il ya quand même des contraintes
aussi juridique qui font qu'aujourd'hui
cette université a du mal à fonctionner
telle qu'elle est définie paramétrer
aujourd'hui par rapport à la loi de 2015
donc à mon avis il ya tout ça à remettre
en question mettre en oeuvre un certain
nombre de préconisations qui me
paraissent intéressantes et évaluer
derrière en fonction des actions si
aujourd'hui il y a lieu de 2,2 de
pouvoir maintenir ce pôle unitaire parce
que c'est sûr que ce pôle université des
antilles est important parce que ça
donne une force et un poids qui est
différent quand on a une université avec
deux pôles au groupe et donc pour nos
étudiants c'est un plus mais il faut
qu'elle arrive à fonctionner cette
université c'est ça le challenge est là
comme bertolo une ou deux universités
aux antilles alors déjà je savais quand
même dire que ce changement faible ce
changement de statut c'est ce c'est ce
qui cristallise en fait une crise qui
perdure depuis quelques temps
effectivement je pense très sincèrement
qu'il faut réaffirmer le principe d'une
université de deux pôles pour moi c'est
quelque chose de clair parce que la
martinique et la guadeloupe a tout à
gagner à rester unis ensemble on est
plus fort et 6
je dois prendre comme exemple ce qui se
fait dans la caraïbe avec l'université
ou des west indies pour moi j'appelle de
mes voeux que l'on trouve une solution
et pour avoir assisté parce que bien
entendu les étudiants du campus caraïbes
et des arts ne sont pas ne sont pas en
dehors de ce qu'il se passe à
l'université pourra voir comment
dirais-je suivi un peu la réunion avec
avec le président de l'ua
il se dit dans un territoire yann a
réaffirmé à réaffirmer le respect
justement de cette équité entre les deux
pôles et surtout le principe de
l'alternance dans la gouvernance qui me
semble quelque quelque chose de
fondamental de 2d essentielle pour que
le université des antilles puisse
continuer à s'épanouir au profit des
étudiants
voilà face à la première
[Musique]
face à la première
le rapatriement de la gestion du revenu
de social d'activité les récentes donc a
été votée par l'assemblée le 7 lors de
la dernière séance plénière du 25 et 26
février dernier
parce que dit louise tel concert à la
somme et président de la commission de
la santé qui appartient au groupe de
pays et ils coûtent trop cher au budget
d'autant que les sommes versées par
l'état ne sont pas suffisants puisque
l'état ne verse pas la totalité de la
somme prévue c'est la collectivité
territoriale de martinique où ailleurs
le département dont 90 dans le reste de
la france qui fait le complément ce
fameux reste à charge aux mondiaux
langage administratif devient de plus en
plus importants 87 millions d'euros en
2020 on aurait pu faire autre chose avec
cet argent que de le payer en supplément
dit louise tél et il ait cet amendement
a été voté à la quasi-unanimité 45 voix
sur 51 élus ce qu'il n'y avait deux ou
trois élus qui n'était pas présent lors
du moment du vote
est ce que c'est une bonne chose marie
faustino que de demander au gouvernement
de rapatrier de reprendre à son compte
une prérogative comme essentielles
concernant la politique d'un social de
la collectivité
c'est un fait je l' ai d'ailleurs voté
et j'avais encore dire que c'est une
mission régalienne à le rsa quand on
voit la collectivité c'est 200 millions
d'euros
les ou 2020 tous de 400 bénéficiaires du
rsa
le chiffre 1 donc on en train de
constater que il ya une croissance
exponentielle et que ça devient
incontrôlable il faut que l'état s'en
charge
la guyane est bien contente aujourd'hui
j'entends la guadeloupe aussi kaki qui
attend donc moi je pense que c'est une
sas la question ne se pose pas il faut
absolument que l'état au point de cette
mission qui est qui fait part d'une de
ses missions régaliennes quoi doper la
guyane que vous citez tout comme la
réunion mayotte ont demandé et obtenu
tout ou partie du rapatriement du rsa va
là nous sommes le dernier des dix huit
ans
outre-mer à le demander est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça nadine morano ou
au contraire faut-il que le système
continue d'exercer sa responsabilité
dans le domaine
je précise humain pour les doutes et aux
internautes que le montant du rsa est
fixé par le gouvernement et non pas par
là c'est en effet le département de la
gironde de la charente maritime c'est ça
justement donc le montant du rsa est
fixé par l'état aussi aujourd'hui la ctm
qui a amené à gérer le paiement de ce
rsa avec un instinct charge considérable
qui pénalise fortement les finances de
la collectivité donc moi je suis tout à
fait favorable à ce que et je crois que
nous l'avions déjà exprimé par le passé
au niveau de l'assemblée ya quelques
années à travers une lettre que le
président lise avait adressé au
président de la république en demandant
la reprise à la charge de l'état de la
gestion du rsa et nous sommes pas les
seuls nombreux de nombreux départements
aujourd'hui sont confrontés aux mêmes
difficultés et demande à l'état de
recentraliser le financement la gestion
du rsa donc moi je suis tout à fait
favorable et je crois que c'est une
nécessité parce que il y va en fait de
la responsabilité de l'état et vous
disiez est ce que en quelques pensons
n'est pas déposséder de notre compétence
mais la compétence sociale elle est
beaucoup plus vaste que ça elle ne se
résume pas au rsa donc il ya encore je
crois que nous avons largement toute
latitude pour pouvoir agir dans le
secteur social en dehors de la partie
purement rsa tout de même manuel la clé
mais en tôle ou en tant que élu
indépendantiste est ce que ça ne vous
paraît pas compliqué de demander à
l'état de reprendre où on met la jsio
est donc de déposséder en quelque sorte
la collectivité d'une partie de son
travail ses prérogatives
alors je suis indépendantiste la
martinique ne vous a pas dit qu'elle est
indépendantiste
donc s'il y a une principe chez les
indépendantistes notamment au mime ses
deux le respect de l'art du choix de la
population
nous nous nous n'imposons rire à la
population cependant on a bien constaté
là encore
que l'état se désengage et donc fait
porter l'odm a la charge au niveau de la
collectivité en cumulé s'est
pratiquement 900 millions de plus donc
voilà c'est une pratiquement 900
millions donc il faut se rendre compte
que l'on ne peut pas donner justement
une prérogative
et puis ne pas donner le financement qui
va avec
donc que l'état reprenne reprenne ses
responsabilités et ensuite nous pouvons
bien sûr sur ses marges dégagées agir
sur le plan social auprès de nous de nos
compatriotes alors en parlant de
responsabilité de la 7e justement le
budget est en train d'être finalisé il
ya eu un débat sur les grandes
orientations la dernière réunion comme
je le disais il ya trois semaines qui
sera mis au vote et 25 et 26 mars
prochains
ce budget de un milliard et 257 millions
d'euros environ contente nombre assez
important de 210 millions d'euros
essentiellement pour faire face aux
effets néfastes de la crise sanitaire
sur le plan économique et social dans
l'opposition tout à l'heure on iphone
qui nous ont dit qu'il n'est pas assez
audacieux assez percutant que la
collectivité aurait pu faire plus et
mieux pour mieux affronter les effets de
la crise sanitaire et refonder la
martinique
alors peut-on peut toujours faire mieux
vous savez on peut toujours proposer
mais même si le budget atteint un
milliard deux cent 200 millions il n'est
pas forcément lastic chez si déjà nous
avons des charges qui ne nous reviennent
pas que nous devons assumer
vous pensez bien que qu'on ne peut pas
tout faire tout tout de suite
cela étant il y a une une gestion
budgétaire et une qui permet d'être au
plus près des attentes et des besoins
par le système des décisions
modificatives et donc on ne peut pas
dire que c'est un budget qui est
une fois voté figé donc il n'ya pas il
n'y a pas lieu de dire ce budget n'a pas
n'a pas l'audace tout au contraire donc
le débat reste ouvert le débat reste
ouvert le débat qui va s'ouvrir ce sera
la can à quelques jours marie von sidow
les 25 et 26 mars prochain qu'est ce que
c'est quoi vous allez contestées la
logique de ce budget parce que c'était
des façons ça a déjà été le cas
oui mais de toutes les façons nous
attendons parce que bon c'est vrai que
l'on reçoit le ont fait le job on ne
savait pas mais morrow son catalogue du
mot d'ordre national
voila voila nous recevrons catalogue
avec beaucoup de choses mais bon on
attend vraiment le recevant le document
pour le budget travailler travailler
travailler parce qu'en fait quand on me
garde
on a l'impression que effectivement il
ya des choses essentielles qui ne sont
pas prises en compte par exemple
par exemple au niveau des écoles au
niveau des écoles par des écoles des
collèges
je pense qu'il faudrait augmenter le
budget à ce niveau là parce que c'est
vrai que ça fait moment bon je ne vais
pas renier j'étais au conseil général je
regarde y'a des liquides et collèges qui
sont toujours dans un état de
délabrement
bon je suis je ne dis pas que le travail
n'a pas été fait parce que j'entends le
cri de madame sa soutane mais
aujourd'hui je pense que les collèges
mériterait mieux
donc il ya d'autres choses il ya
l'accompagnement des familles
alors il ya des difficultés ayant marre
parce que bon c'est vrai que lorsque
j'ai vu le dob
d'ailleurs j'ai dû faire un collier en
perles cry 2
la crue de commander un cri du coeur
mais pourquoi parce que j'étais en
plénière et ja j'ai fait une
intervention sur la bas vous vous rendez
compte que vous faites une intervention
sur la part d'un des trois plaignants
tromper nir ça fait trois mois est la
réponse qui m'a été donnée
j'étais vraiment j'avais l'impression
que j'allais mourir en ce jour là je me
dis j'attends le l'exécutif c'est vrai
qu'il a dit cela il a eu le courage de
dire l'audace de dire que oui il ya des
problèmes
vous pouvez me dire que l'on me donne un
tel catalogue et puis autant de
problèmes au niveau de des personnes
âgées on parle de comment dirais-je des
personnes âgées ou dans le dans le dob
débat d'orientation budgétaire 2021 sera
l'année de la bienséance des personnes
âgées
il ya un problème quand vous avez
quelqu'un qui tu es la pa pou sa maman
qui prononce cependant ça fait sept mois
et ça fait quatre mois que je ça fait
plus de quatre mois que je le dis ayant
problème c'est parti donc moi je dis que
mon cadeau de quelques problèmes
le problème particulier la polémique
soulevée à voulait que je reste radio
que au niveau de la part vous savez il
ya tout un processus pour que la
personne l aide personnalisée
d'autonomie
il ya en visite ou b soit comme avec le
court vite
ça se fait par téléphone je ne sais pas
après et un plan d'aidé le plan des de
la famille valider ça revient il ya une
notification une notification jusqu'à ce
jour n'a ne parvient pas la famille pour
qu'elle puisse mettre en place le le
lapin pour pouvoir donner à la personne
qui vient travailler chaque jour donc
les familles sont en souffrance
donc il ya des aides ménagères qui ne
peuvent bouger réellement parce que le
dossier traîne n'ont jamais dit que
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise et avec tout ça le social c'est la
collectivité le chef de file de l'action
sociale
c'était le conseil général nos joues tu
sais il ya tellement je ne vais pas
critiquer je ne sais pas une critique
c'est un constat parce je ne dis pas que
rien n'a pas été
je n'ai pas été fait je vais pas le dire
parce que je vois les administratifs ils
travaillent ils font l'autre il faut le
boulot il faut le boulot on peut même
pas poser des questions ils sont
impuissants quelquefois je sais pas ce
qui se passe ensuite moi je me pose la
question
donc il faut qu'on accepte que les
certains élus fassent un constat c'est
juste un constat
parce que de comptes ont fait le tour de
la martinique sur les réseaux sociaux
quand vous rend compte que des gens
aient un problème donc on va voter un
budget mais il faut que ce budget là
tient compte des réalités et des vrais
besoins d'une des martiniquais jean reno
qu'elles sont
les 40 principales qui vous paraissent
figurer dans ce budget qu'est ce qui lui
manque
alors donc landu de la dernière plénière
donc nous avons effectivement débattu
dans le cadre du débat d'orientation
budgétaire sur les orientations qui nous
était proposé maintenant nous attendons
de voir le budget qui va émerger de ce
que nous avons fait remonter au sein de
l'assemblée je crois qu'il ya eu de
nombreuses interventions sur différents
aspects mais pour ma part je crois que
ce budget ce but ce budget pour qu'ils
soient en adéquation avec les réalités
et les enjeux de notre territoire
aujourd'hui en plus avec cette crise
sanitaire que nous venons de 2 subie en
depuis déjà plus d'un an je crois qu'il
ya un certain nombre d'enjeux en matière
de développement économique de relance
de notre activité économique et de
préservation de ce qui ce qui a pu
survivre traverser cette crise je crois
qu'il faut déployer des efforts
conséquents pour maintenir notre tissu
économique à flot et permettre un
développement de notre série 3 sur
différents axes 1 que ce soit le
développement économique le tourisme
l'agriculture plus précisément puisque
c'est le champ sur lequel j'interviens
il ya un certain nombre de choses
concernant ces axes la notamment qui
n'apparaissent pas dans les orientations
qui nous ont été proposées et c'est pour
cela que nous avons demandé en
l'occurrence sur l'agriculture j'ai
demandé à ce qu'un certain nombre de
préconisations que j'avais formulée lors
d'une plénière du mois de mai pour une
relance de la du secteur agricole suite
aux convives puissent être reprises dans
ce budget et qu'on retrouve ces
orientations et les financement adéquat
pouvoir mener ses actions de
redynamisation de notre tissu économique
je crois que la problématique des
seniors l'accompagnement la prise en
charge des seniors à travers un certain
nombre de projets
innovants et structurants doit également
être renforcée et puis notre jeunesse il
ya encore beaucoup beaucoup à faire pour
cette jeunesse pour lutter contre la
baisse démographique le départ de nos
jeunes favoriser le retour en dhr la
martinique plus attractive aussi pour
cette jeunesse et nous avons un travail
à faire en ce sens et puis un certain
nombre d'enjeux et d'objectifs qui
avaient été définis dans le ftd 2i c'est
à dire le schéma territorial de
développement économique d'innovation et
d'internationalisation que nous avons
votée il ya quelques années ne n'était
pas non plus repris dans ce dans ce
document faisant apparaître les
orientations donc c'est tout ça qu'il
faut aujourd'hui qu'on puisse retrouver
dans le budget qui nous sera soumis
prochainement donc j'espère que les
observations et toutes les propositions
des dix collègues en assemblées auront
été reprise dans ce budget que nous
allons découvrir prochainement et sur
lequel nous allons nous exprimer du lac
léman berthelot vous qui êtes rocher
l'exécutif vous avez des informations
des garanties selon lesquelles mais
c'est les observations des membres de
l'opposition des membres de l'assemblée
seront seront prises en compte pour un
débat je rappelle que le monsieur budget
si studio c'est miguel laventure aurait
chargé à l'exécutif des affaires
budgétaires et le président de la
commission des finances étant michel
brouche y est ce que vous pensez que
l'opposition sera écoutée alors non il
ne s'agit pas de se dire si on sera
écoutée ou pas ce qu'il est important de
dire sait déjà que c'est un débat
d'orientation et le débat d'orientation
justement c'est pour engager le débat et
écouter entendre parce que les
propositions ne sont pas venu que deux
que de l'opposition à les propositions
aussi sont venues dès la majorité par
exemple je me rappelle avoir fait un
focus sur les métiers du médico social
parce que c'est effectivement une série
qui qui
ce qui m'importe beaucoup dans la mesure
où nous avons une une démographie qui
est d'un bilan démographique est un peu
inquiétant puisque on où il est prévu
que nous soyons le des lunes de l'un des
territoires les plus les plus âgés pour
ne pas dire le plus vieux mais donc en
fait les propositions viennent d'un peu
partout et pour dire encore plus les
choses
le président de la commission que vous
avez cité monsieur branché de la
commission finances a proposé
effectivement une commission élargie
alors je ne me rappelle pas très bien la
date où effectivement il y avait encore
matière à discuter a proposé le
conseiller exécutif
mais quelle aventure effectivement
étaient présents et les doléances les
demandes ont été ont été enregistrées
donc nous irons très bien que des
propositions pour être entendus ils sont
entendus d'ailleurs dans beaucoup de cas
l'eau je voulais quand même féru petit
une petite remarque il peut y avoir sur
certains dossiers concernant la pac
quelques difficultés mais ça ne peut pas
en faire une généralité
on ne peut pas en faire une généralité
parce que les dossiers sont sont traités
je peux dire que les délais de
traitement ont été très raccourcie alors
que des dossiers avant qu'ils ne qui se
traitaient des francs 1 en deux ans et
bien aujourd'hui on a des dossiers qui
qui peuvent se traiter beaucoup plus
rapidement donc c'est vrai qu'il y à des
situations compliquées il ya des
situations complexes et il faut il faut
pouvoir les entendre mais on ne peut pas
faire une généralité locaux mais là
dessus parce que je trouve je trouve pas
normal
déjà que quand plaignants on est à
intervenir sur un dossier n'a pas
j'étais au conseil général je n'ai
jamais connu ça
je n'ai jamais connu ça je ne l'étais je
suis gêné d'intervenir sur ça mais le
problème c'est pas une généralité soir
il ya eu un dossier ya pas qu un dossier
il n'y a pas que le seuil à plusieurs
dossiers
et lorsque là il ya un problème je sais
pas monsieur
le conseil exécutif a dit effectivement
martinois résulats répéter vous pouvez
avoir un public aux exécutifs de vous
faire donc c'est à dire que lorsque vous
venez en plénière vous venez en deuxième
ligne on va vers un troisième ligne vous
dit la même chose ce qui est un problème
donc c'est pas le fait de dire ce serait
jamais venu pour moi c'est des choses
qui se règlent le président les noms
anglais pas ces problèmes là ça se
passait et puis signée manger du conseil
général j'étais dans la commission
affaires sociales
je n'ai jamais connu ça aujourd'hui la
situation est encore plus grave
donc les dossiers n'avancent pas je n'ai
jamais connu cette situation
je suis désolé alors justement rester
avec nos frais d'un petit notion stella
vous avez fait une
remarque lors de la dernière plénière
vous êtes montrés j'allais dire agacé du
la teneur des débats
je vous cite de mémoire de chamailleries
de questions inutiles l'intervention
rallonge en critiquant certains élus qui
n'ont pas grand chose à dire mais qui
allonge les débats d'autant que c'est
d'autant plus difficile que vous étiez
jusqu'à présent aux visioconférences à
distance donc c'est pas facile de 6 ou
là les plaignants certains n'étaient pas
attentif a été le cas mais en fait vous
êtes montré agacé mais bon ça peut ça
peut arriver que dans une union qui dure
deux fois deux journées on peut avoir
des moments de relâchement non vous
parlez de wallace mc cain niveau non il
a dit qu'il ya un comportement
effectivement que vous avez dénoncé mais
est ce qu'il ne peut pas se comprendre
vu la manière dont les élus travaillent
depuis le trailer et salomon non même
supporter si vous voyez les plénières
c'est pas d'aujourd'hui incendié par la
ctm seulement c'est moi je en fait ça
fait un moment que je me dis non mais ce
n'est pas possible
j'aime au fisc et il avait 13 ans elle
en a 24 aujourd'hui j'étais au conseil
général
et je crois comme ça on garde une
plénière on a rappelé une plénière
c'était juste parce que je ne suis pas
je peux pas vous dire si c'est là
c'était cela le conseil général et le
conseil régional et la forme du moment
c'est dans ce sens que tu vas tu parles
tu passe des journées denses à leucate
la femme a dit ça je me suis dit voir
des comptes les lisent les enfants
voient le comportement des élus en
plénière ça fait il avait 13 ans à 24
alors que je suis arrivé à ce thème
le premier jour il en a ils ont affiché
un comportement le dernier jour parce
que nous étions considérés comme des
animaux nous nous quand on arrivait donc
j'ai parfois ça c'est pas ça le débat
d'aujourd'hui nous parler de leur nom
c'est à dire qu'il y avait des il y
avait des commentaires y avait des
choses lorsqu'on s'exprime mais moi
j'avais jamais disent non nous sommes
des martiniquais nous sommes venus
travailler pour le thé martiniquais nous
sommes une opposition aujourd'hui
peut-être qu'il ya eu des choses je ne
sais pas peut-être que une gestion
peut-être je n'étais pas au conseil
régional jeu des pages et au conseil
général
mais y'a pas je ne sais pas on parle de
gestion calamiteuse mais ça ne peut pas
on a parlé de ça mais ça ne peut pas on
ne peut pas aussi 30 des hommes des
êtres humains des gens des collègues
et puis un certain nombre de choses ça
faisait un moment que ça dure c'est un
moment de relâchement et tout le temps
quand vous traversez les rues chaudes
café la zone principale
je vais pas tous les élus entendent ça
tous les élus entendent ça donc moi un
moment donné on passe des plaignants on
est parti sur une journée de plein air
on a à deux journées de prévenir avec 80
points
on est fatigué on est fatigué devant
l'école on est fatigués en présentiel
donc on est quand même qu'on doit
pouvoir travailler moi je ne peux
prendre deux jours plénière en
visioconférence en présentiel
mais dans un climat ou sur vos gardes
ont pu rigoler etc
mais on entend des choses ouais c'est la
ligne rouge a dit à celle non il ya des
choses qu'on peut pas entendre il faut
que les gens se il faut que nous
respections pour que nous puissions
montrer aux martiniquais que nous sommes
venus travailler pour défendre leurs
intérêts c'est seulement ça alors
maintenant line renaud
j'entends bien d'autres façons nous
verrons bien quelle est l'ambiance le
climat la prochaine plaignants puisque
ce sera en présentiel comme on dit une
ville un mot qui sont physiquement vous
serez présents à l'hémicycle de la cité
mcl unis madame non une question de
manière plus générale ce budget présenté
comme un accord de pour courir refonder
la martinique m'en tape à savoir qu'est
ce que ça veut dire exactement cette
refondation comment vous voyez que la 7e
pourrait s'orienter pourrait travailler
pour participer justement à la
refondation à la reconstruction à la
relance de l'économie mais delà de la
vie sociale en général
alors personnellement le terme de
refondation je ne me reconnais pas je ne
souscris pas cette appellation de
refondation
je crois que
il aurait fallu appeler ça autrement je
crois que aujourd'hui la martinique a
besoin d'une nouvelle dynamique de
nouvel élan de sur un certain nombre de
champs on a parlé de l'est de
l'éducation on a parlé des saignant du
développement économique du tourisme en
fait il ya plein dax sur lesquels
aujourd'hui il y a lieu de redynamiser
et puisqu'on est toujours sur le budget
moi ce que ce que je voudrais dire aussi
concernant ce débat d'orientation
budgétaire
ce que nous avons enfin en tout cas pour
ma part regretté aussi c'est qu'il n'y
ait pas eu de co construction de ces
orientations
enfin de deschamps jeu préalable afin
que nous puissions chacun donc ça se
passe en plénière mais vous voyez là
déjà la durée des plénières donc quand
on a une plaignante qui dure deux jours
et qu'on est obligé de profiter de ce
temps là pour pouvoir échanger faire des
propositions sur quelque chose de
stratégique comme les orientations
budgétaires dans ce contexte en plus
particulier dans lequel nous sommes
je pense que ça se prépare en amont ça
nous éviterait d'avoir des plénières qui
dure jusqu'à minuit 1h du matin et
savait pas soucier de nos travaux de
préparatoire non nous avons reçu ce
document avec les orientations
budgétaires mais nous n'avons pas été
associés
donc nous et c'est pour cela que du coup
nous faisons des remontées en plénière
qui vont être ensuite traitées et on va
nous représenter un budget mais l'idéal
aurait été c'est ce que c'est ce que je
regrette c'est que nous ayons pas la
possibilité chacun dans son champ
d'intervention respectifs et d'ailleurs
nous sommes élus nous avons certes des
des champs d'intervention mais nous
avons un avis sur tout les tous les
sujets et des propositions à faire que
nous puissions travailler c'est en amont
et faire des propositions est arrivé en
plénière avec déjà un document
suffisamment exhaustif sur les
orientations que nous voulons proposer
pour notre territoire en débattre
ensuite par la suite j'ai deux questions
vous maniez l'acclament bertolo
sur la forme oui la forme si vous
l'association sous la co construction
d'un simple et deux à plein de l'absence
elle aussi quelque chose qu'il faut
qu'il faut surtout retenir c'est que la
collectivité territoriale est formé de
deux instances donc il y à l'assemblée
il ya le conseil exécutif
et rien n'empêche je ne suis pas
président de commission mais rien
n'empêche à une commission de se réunir
et de travailler sur un sujet
effectivement le débat d'orientation est
proposée par comme en images par le
conseil exécutif
mais effectivement on sait que qui ont
un débat d'orientation qui va ce qui se
prépare rien n'empêche à une commission
de chevet du de s'autosaisir de se
réunir et de travailler sur un sujet et
donc ensuite d'exposer et de faire
remonter ses attentes sur sur d'aubaine
quelle qu'elle soit donc la construction
peut se fait effectivement il y a
aujourd'hui il y a eu le débat
d'orientation il y a eu ensuite une
réunion comme une commission élargie où
tous les tous les présidents étaient
étaient invités s'étaient aussi là
l'occasion de faire remonter pour faire
remonter les attentes les besoins les
doléances les critiques pourquoi pas
pour effectivement que ça puisse
s'enrichir et enrichir les éléments du
budget alors s'il le faut qu est ce que
ça veut dire aux fondations pour vous
alors il faut il faut effectivement
prendre en compte le contexte dans
lequel nous sommes trouvés ou la crise
sanitaire a tout bousculé véritable tout
bousculer et de déstructurer le tissu
économique
alors je peux en parler très bien
surtout dans le même domaine de
domaine artistique de la culture on a vu
les artistes se sont retrouvés dans des
situations très compliquées avec le
confinement
avec la fermeture ou d'aider des lieux
d'expression et donc où la collectivité
a dû comment dirais-je venir en soutien
sur six est sûre c'est sur ces sujets
sous ces points et donc il a fallu
effectivement je vais dire remettre en
place restructurer refaire un nouveau
modèle proposer quelque chose de
différent pour que nous puissions
continuer à fonctionner et ce qu'il faut
aussi retenir c'est la réactivité de la
collectivité
parce que en plus de ces de cette crise
sanitaire nous avons également connu
j'avais dit les intempéries avec tout au
long de son palais voilà nous arrivions
pilotes nous sommes nous sommes très
souvent ils le feront sera également
touchée et donc il faut de la réactivité
il faut effectivement tout cela doit
être
je l'avais dit au roi pensée réinventer
et cette refondation elle doit prendre
en compte effectivement et d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que c'est autour de lui
mais devra prendre en compte l'homme le
mettre au centre des choses et trouver
un nouveau modèle où il faudra
effectivement travailler en réseau serré
pour que le tissu économique on puisse
retrouver un peu plus de 2 km ou de mort
aux dents voilà donc nous aurons
l'occasion de nous revoir mesdames un
lobby très bientôt puisque l'émission
quasiment tous chasse a fait si vous
êtes élu de la 7e vous êtes tous les
lieux également d'une région de
martinique
oui j'ai envie d'apporter damoclès
bertolo françois pour par iphone ch'ti
no7 paris pour d'indy d'honneur juste
une dernier en question sous forme de
témoignage commun de vous personne
arrivée à la politique marie von sydow
c'est juste pour terminer notre savait
et j'aime à le dire je suis plutôt une
femme associatif et c'est vrai que
lorsqu'on fait beaucoup de vie
associative on n'est pas rassurant sans
même pas compte et c'est ce qu'ils
disent est donc alors donc la vie
associative en donne donc un homme
simple des lions continuent de donner
voilà l'association est un tremplin
politique anti chambre
je ne sais pas ça les gars vous fait
tellement de choses on vous appelle vous
déviez tu vas faire plus on y va et puis
après on est pris là dedans c'est tout
ce qui vous arrive est aussi des
dinosaures oui j'ai été sollicité à la
fois par des militants et c'est comme ça
que je suis venu à la vie politique avec
le la modeste contribution que je peux
apporter en fonction de mes compétences
donc pour moi l'objectif et c'est pour
ça aussi peut-être que le fait d'être
sans étiquette facilite peut-être aussi
les choses parce que bon finalement on
n'est pas forcément pris dans les
logiques de parenty et dans les
querelles de parenty peut-être
et ça permet de s'investir comme on voit
de plus en plus de personnes de la
société civile s'investissent un temps
pour apporter la contribution qu'elles
peuvent à fonctionnement de la société
voilà un peu de 8h familiale dans votre
cas oui enfin faut dire que j'ai été un
peu baissé la politique et je me suis
retrouvé sur des disques et aux deux
conférences à l'âge de 14 ans donc je
pense que ça laisse des traces
mais voilà donc je pense qu'il ya un peu
de ça aussi il ya l'engagement familiale
qui se transmet et puis la volonté de
travailler pour son pays
voilà avec votre père guy renard que
nous saluons ici dans votre goût de
contrôle kamanyola clemes bertolo alors
effectivement aussi je viens du monde
associatif mais c'est surtout aussi le
fait de pouvoir servir servi mon pays
servir une cause ce que je trouve juste
et faire effectivement que la question
identitaire soit soit posée c'est ce qui
me ce qui m'inspire en politique et puis
des valeurs fortes que je souhaiterais
retrouver parce que je pense que pour
biais des billets des situations
certains se sont éloignés de ses valeurs
nobles
merci madame mais manu la clé en main
tout le madame nadine renard et madame
francine d'avoir participé à notre
émission aujourd'hui réalisé par cédric
berthe les airs aux mécaniques soit la
retrouverez demain lundi si notre site
internet dans quelques instants ce sera
le journal de la rédaction de martinique
la première pour les dernières
informations
je vous donne rendez vous dimanche
prochain avant de vous séparer je vous
repose cette citation de michelle obama
un grand politique s'il a neigé l'acide
ça nous permettra de méditer durant le
reste du week-end
la seule limite à la hauteur de vos
réalisations est la portée de vos rêves
et votre volonté de travailler dur pour
les réaliser à bientôt
hier
[Musique]
a three mis à l'eau